j'avais lu une phrase dans un livre que
je trouvais très parlante c'est être
féministe est une forme d'amour qu'on se
donne à sa mère
[Musique]
j'ai été victime de viol lorsque j'étais
enfant par un voisin et du coup j'ai mis
de nombreuses années à guérir de ce
traumatisme à la c'est le lieu
où je me suis en partie reconstruite et
j'aime beaucoup dire parce que comme
celui établi à l'hôpital delafontaine
machine à l'hôpital delafontaine donc
j'aime beaucoup dire que je suis né deux
fois dans ce lieu là
[Musique]
aujourd'hui ce que j'aime beaucoup dire
que mme itto finalement c'était que les
murmures et son considère que mais tout
ça file du prix 20 par rapport à la
réalité de ce que représentent les
violences sexuelles s'était finalement
qu'à murmuré pour moi il ya vraiment
urgence à ce qu'on en parle de manière
collective et que on avait en fait
toutes les consciences
[Musique]
être une femme musulmane a un coût c'est
un coup parce que en termes de
discrimination par exemple dans l'accès
à l'emploi etc les femmes musulmanes
notamment lorsqu'elles sont voilées
lorsqu'elle porte le voit c'est beaucoup
plus compliqué d'accéder à l'emploi donc
à toutes les prières étaient que ça
suppose
m